the show opens in India introducing us
to two best friends sunny and fos they
are currently abducted by some gangsters
and are forcefully taken to a villa far
away from the city upon arriving there a
gang leader interrogates them about a
fake bank note a few months prior to
this event Sunny is shown as an
exceptionally skilled street artist
capable of replicating any famous
paintings with Precision with this
Talent he creates and sells intricate
artworks at bargain prices in the
streets it turns out that he inherited
this artistic gift from his Grand father
madav who not only creates art but also
runs a newspaper company called konti
magazine which isn't doing very well
don't worry Grandpa TV will be screwed
soon too one day as Sunny finishes a new
painting for his grandfather the pair
discuss the future of the company modav
believes that their magazines will one
day spread to a broader audience online
but sunny and fos don't have any
positive hopes at all regardless they
have been helping him run the press
since childhood during break time Sunny
recalls how the company started when he
and fal's were kids they used to sell
newspapers on every street corner but
the people weren't interested in reading
them instead the newspapers were used to
wrap food and sleep on despite this the
kids used to try their best to sell it
and hid the earnings in mv's drawer to
surprise him as time passed Sunny who
was more interested in drawing and
painting honed those skills while fos
learned printing from Uncle Yasir one of
the oldest employees of konti magazine
despite their talents they face
financial difficulties and continuously
seek alternative means of earning money
ah hustle culture healthy I wonder if
they've tried Fiverr apart from all this
sunny has a wealthy girlfriend named an
one day as they are having a romantic
moment in an's car she shares her plan
to celebrate the upcoming new year at an
upscale restaurant eager to align with
his partner's affluent lifestyle Sunny
impulsively agrees to accompany her
unaware of the cost involved behind it
later on sunny and FAS visit the
restaurant to inquire about the prices
only to be shocked by the Steep rates
the manager then humiliates them rud
rudely and sends them away be gone urgin
the scene then cuts to New Year's Eve
and sunny and his friends are seen
enjoying a local rooftop party shortly
after Anna joins them but she quickly
grows uncomfortable with the
surroundings which don't match her level
as a result she leaves to celebrate the
occasion with her other wealthy friends
in the high-end Club following this
sunny and fos find a quiet corner and
talk about their ongoing predicament
frustrated with their evergoing
struggles Sunny asserts that the
middleclass people like themselves
receive no respect and that they spend
their entire lives burdened by Deb bang
on sunny on the following day sunny
arrives at the printing press only to
find that none of the employees are
working upon inquiring about the
situation his grandfather reveals that
loan recovery agents were sent by a
money lender Mr rattin LA and they have
demanded full repayment of their debt
within 30 days the grandfather seems to
have tried every means possible to
gather money but to no avail feeling
defeated he decides to shut down the
company but before that he thinks of
publishing one last edit torial
concerned for their grandfather sunny
and fos visit Mr rattin LA's office
hoping to negotiate some more time to
repay their debts however the old man
doesn't want to listen to them left with
no other option the two decide to use
all of their savings and sell Sunny's
paintings as well as their bikes despite
doing all of this they still fall short
of the required amount fos then seeks
help from his dubious friend Anise who
introduces him to mja a skilled forger
before engaging in any dealings with mja
sunny proposes a plan to produce their
own counterfeit money using his
replication skills and F Ro's printing
expertise although hesitant at first fos
eventually agrees you can't be in debt
if you're in prison and the two of them
start working on this risky Venture
together in the aftermath Sunny
meticulously examines a 500 rupe note
using his extraordinary artistic skills
in order to forge it flawlessly he
ensures that every single line and micr
letter are replicated accurately even
going so far as to copy the watermark
once the design is fin finalized FAS
utilizes his knowledge of ink colors to
achieve accurate printing however this
process proves to be challenging due to
their old printers limitation of
producing only one color at a time they
then use a strip of glitter for the
security strip and stamp the serial
numbers in different sizes before
cutting the forged notes to the exact
dimensions in order to give an authentic
touch they lastly dip the notes in tea
and leave them to get dry once this
entire process is completed the duo
visit a nearby liquor store to test
their creation they hand over the note
and exchange for the liquor but the
store owner immediately recognizes the
fake note by simply touching it as a
consequence they are chased by the owner
as well as other customers they managed
to escape unharmed but just by the Skin
of Their Teeth despite this failure
Sunny isn't ready to give up so he vows
to make even more perfect notes in the
next scene we are introduced to a
highlevel counterfeiting Mafia mansur
Dalal who arrives in Katmandu Nepal via
his private jet it appears that Monsour
has been involved in the illegal
production of Indian currency in the
Middle East he packages the counterfeit
money in Nepal for distribution
throughout India currently Monsour
proceeds to a secret hotel to meet with
his distributor named belal unaware of
the fact that a group of police officers
have set up a sting operation to capture
him the cops are led by Michael
vinayagam oh my God that was bad Michael
vedanayagam who seems to have been
chasing him for more than six years as
soon as they learn about mansur's
arrival they immediately make their way
towards the same location shortly after
the officers raid the SEC Hideout and
apprehend Monsour and his associates but
before they can take them to the police
van monsour's other henchmen open fire
on the officers amidst the ensuing chaos
Monsour manages to escape gunning down
one of Michael's colleagues in the
process unfortunately for Monsour even
if he escapes this he'll still be in
trouble elsewhere Sunny realizes that
they used the wrong quality of paper on
their note which is why they got caught
determined to rectify this flaw the two
start searching for paper that closely
resembles the texture of J genuine
currency maybe they should just print it
on money after days of exploring various
options they finally come across a
suitable paper with the desired
consistency they then proceed to bleach
the paper and print the currency design
on both sides before soaking it in tea
once done they visit another crowded
local store to test their second
creation much to their surprise it is
approved finally confirming that the
quality of their counterfeit money is
perfect or maybe the store employee was
being paid minimum wage so they didn't
give a damn back and the presid seen the
one interrogating sunny and fos is
revealed to be none other than mansur in
an effort to save his best friend Sunny
confesses that he's the one responsible
for creating the fake note upon hearing
this Revelation Monsur and his men
unexpectedly leave the scene following
this sunny reflects on his past when he
was only 7 years old after the death of
his mother he and his father used to
relocate from one place to another to
avoid money lenders but on one fateful
day his father ran away leaving him
alone on a train since then then Sunny
started Living on train platforms
creating artworks in hopes that his
father would recognize him through his
drawings this is when he met fos and the
two began working together as days
passed by Sunny realized that his father
had purposefully abandoned him although
in reality he was killed several days
later Sunny's grandfather found him
bringing both him and fos home in the
present we are introduced to Maga an
employee from The Reserve Bank of India
who is in the middle of briefing a group
of ministers about the issue of
counterfeiting she also presents a
revolution machine called ct600 to
combat the fake notes unfortunately her
efforts are in vain as the higher
ranking officials show no interest and
pay little attention to the matter after
her presentation Michael approaches the
Finance Minister poan gallot and informs
him about the current state of the
counterfeiting gig he requests for a
dedicated team to combat and eradicate
the ongoing Financial terrorism however
powan is solely focused on the upcoming
election campaign so he disregards
Michael's concerns that night Michael
gets Dr drunk and ends up blackmailing
Pawan with his private pictures to gain
his cooperation help me with the money
thing or I leak the dick piics on the
other hand sunny and FAS make waves with
their fake notes at one point in time
they fix a meeting with a fake note
dealer named lad kaala the boys showcase
their remarkably authentic fake notes
impressing the dealer right away lad
koala then inquires about the price to
which Sunny proposes a rate of 200
rupees for a 500 rupe fake note the
latter counters with an offer of 150
rupees and places a substantial order of
fake notes worth two CR furthermore the
order must be delivered in a time frame
of 2 weeks a challenge that Sunny is
ready to accept after the meeting fos
who is astounded by the scale of the
order questions Sunny about how they'll
produce such a large quantity in such a
short time frame he also emphasizes the
need for real money to invest in making
the fake money however Sunny appears
unphased and decides to approach Mr
rattin law in order to request some
additional funds Sunny assures Mr rattin
law that they will repay their entire
higher loan within a month seeing the
confidence Mr rattin law agrees but
imposes an interest rate of 24% f o is
uncertain but Sunny plunges into the
agreement with confidence believing that
this time will be different from this
point onwards the two begin their work
one day Uncle yir confronts Sunny about
the banknote sketches hidden in the
drawer now that he is caught Sunny
Reveals His illegal work citing his
motive to save the printing house and
his financially struggling grandfather
he then shows one of the counterfeit
notes which leaves uncle
shocked he asks the uncle to help them
in their operation but the latter is
scared of getting caught in a bid to
persuade him Sunny takes him to a
restaurant and uses the fake note to pay
for food initially Uncle yir panics but
he is relieved when the restaurant owner
accepts the note without suspicion this
ultimately convinces him to join their
Endeavor in order to accelerate their
Pace they also acquire new Printing and
drawing machines on the other hand
Michael visits powan in his office and
apologizes for his earlier Behavior he
then asks him to approve his
counterfeiting team guaranteeing that if
this operation is successful Pan's name
will be even more popular meanwhile
Sunny's team faces a problem they
struggle to find the specific GSM paper
required for making the fake notes in
search of a solution they turn to Anise
who then brings along his henchmen to
carry out a robbery at a paper Factory
the most boring robbery of all time in
the middle of the night they Infiltrate
The Factory premises and to cost all the
guards in a corner while one group holds
the guards at gunpoint the other group
including Sunny FZ and others Venture
inside to find the desired paper shortly
after they locate it but Sunny decides
to steal other random-sized paper in
order to avoid suspicion from the police
more theft equals less trouble now that
they have all the resources they need
the trio Works tirelessly for days and
nights to fulfill their huge order they
managed to complete their operation just
before the deadline following this they
deliver the fake currency to Lad koala
and receive real money in return before
departing the dealer notes that he will
need their services again with their
illicit Enterprise thriving they
gradually pay off all their debts along
with its interest thereby rescuing konti
magazine even though in the future
nothing can save Kony magazine when
Sunny's grandfather questions about the
source of funds Sunny makes up a story
about starting a new business with a new
partner Who provided a loan though the
grandfather appears suspicious this is a
good thing for him so he doesn't care
the following day sunny takes an to a
fancy restaurant as a date as usual she
discreetly hands her credit card to the
waiter assuming her boyfriend friend
doesn't have money when Sunny sees this
he becomes upset to add to his worries
Ana reveals that she's being pressured
by her parents to marry a rich man so
she might have to stop seeing him after
their meal Sunny goes to the counter and
asks the waiter to return ania's credit
card leaving some fake notes instead
wasn't the point to impress her to her
face why did he do that coincidentally
Maga also arrives in the same restaurant
for dinner turns out her mother has set
up a blind date for her but she's not
looking forward to it at all after the
awkward date ends the the two split the
bill mea receives counterfeit notes and
change which she recognizes immediately
she then collects all the 500 rupe notes
from the counter and takes them for
further investigation after working late
hours she finally figures out that the
bill is a sandwich note the hell does
that mean elsewhere Michael receives a
call from the Finance Minister who
finally agrees to provide him with a
counterfeiting team he asked for however
Michael must help him in winning the
upcoming election in return with this
grant Michael pledges to eradicate
counterfeiting Nation wide on the other
hand sunny and FAS are so driven by
greed that they persuade Uncle yir to
print another batch of fake notes
despite his reluctance the very next day
Michael conducts a briefing for his
newly assembled team about mansur Dalal
and his illicit operations he outlines
mansur's extensive network spread across
neighboring countries he also introduces
shakar as the chief investigating
officer who will be assisting the
special task force in this Mission as
their first step of the mission Michael
and Shear retriev the counterfeit
currency conf at from Nepal for
examination later on Michael uses some
of those notes to purchase new
smartphones gifting one to shakar and
keeping the other for his six-year-old
son vom simultaneously mea approaches
her boss Primal with a request she wants
to investigate the counterfeit notes she
uncovered earlier however her boss
dismisses the idea asserting that the
national investigation agency or nia has
jurisdiction over the case and that they
don't have authority to intervene in
such a matter 2 weeks later megar
requests permission again and this time
she is allowed to join Michael's team in
another scene sunny and fos receive a
call from lad koala who informs them
that his big boss has a huge project for
them and asks them to come to an address
following this the two best friends head
to the location which turns out to be a
lavish Club there they meet their client
casari B Doshi who is revealed to be a
legislative assembly member casari Bai
proposes a deal involving 20 CR fake
notes their largest deal till now with
greater deals come greater risk as they
themselves have to deliver the notes
across state borders despite the high
stakes sunny and FZ agree to the deal
but they now have to find the required
paper stealing from the previous Factory
is unfeasible due to the large order so
they come up with another plan they
register a fictitious company with the
name mkg publishing and also hire a
receptionist this gives them an alibi
for buying the amount of paper they need
elsewhere Michael attends his son's
birthday party despite the fact that
he's not invited what the heck I didn't
invite Dad here it's revealed that he
shares a strained relationship with his
wife due to which they live separately
the scene then shifts to Maga who visits
Michael's office to join his special
task force she submits a resume and even
presents her invention the ct600 to him
to test her capabilities Michael hands
her a counterfeit bank note which is
quickly flagged by her machine she also
assures that she can install this chip
in every cash machine this convinces
Michael and he quickly hires her for the
team the very next day at work megop
presents evidence of the counterfeit
bank note from the restaurant hoping for
an investigation however Michael
dismisses her concern asserting that
their top priority is to capture mensur
despite this refusal mea clandestinely
uses his stamp to approve an order
letter for her investigation the only
way to beat counterfeit is with
counterfeit she then presents the letter
to a sub inspector and asks him to
accompany her to check nearby printing
presses upon wandering around for the
entire day they head for their last
destination konti magazine in the
meantime Sunny FZ and uncle yir are in
the middle of printing the fake notes
for their new or a short while later
they hear a police siren and cautiously
watch through the window as the police
approach the building the trio
immediately turn off the lights and stay
as silent as possible making it appear
that the Press is closed however the
ongoing money printing process needs 15
more minutes to be completed so Uncle
yir walks out through the back door and
approaches the police in an attempt to
buy some time for the boys inside he
engages the officer in conversation
hello officer sure it's a nice day for
laundering money uh for what do we do
magazines at the same time mea slowly
approaches the entrance prompting the
boys to turn off the printing machine
she suspects that something fishy is
going on inside so she demands that the
door be opened Uncle yir tries his best
to send her away but when she insists he
reluctantly opens the door fortunately
just before Maga enters the premises
sunny and FAS hastily grab all the
printed reels and hide inside a cabin
Maga and the police officer then walk in
and begin their inspection she slowly
walks towards the trash bin containing
some evidence about the illicit
activities seeing this sunny prepares a
wrench in one hand and sneaks behind her
but to their Good Fortune megar receives
a call from an angry Michael who
confronts her about forging his stamp he
orders her to abandon the inspection and
return right away as a result of this
she and the police officer walk away
allowing the trio to breathe a sigh of
relief following this the three of them
continue with their work not long after
modav unexpectedly shows up with some
bundles of fake money in hand he notices
the boys printing the fake notes but
appears to be confused unaware of the
ongoing situation he hands over money to
Sunny instructing him to pay off their
debts here it's revealed that the old
man is suffering from dementia and it's
getting worse in the aftermath Sunny
perceives their entire Endeavor as a
blessing from God reassuring uncle yir
that they on the right path the next day
sunny and fos load all the counterfeit
notes onto a truck and head towards
their delivery destination Surat on
Route they come across a checkpoint
where two police officers stop them and
demand to inspect the track the officers
begin opening each box only to find
telephone directories inside turns out
that the boys have cleverly concealed
the fake notes underneath the thick
directories disguising the upper portion
of the boxes however their plan
nearly unravels when one of the officers
starts inspecting below the directories
sensing the danger Sunny deliberately
creates a clicking sound come on man
come on man you hear that right
diverting their attention to some wine
bottles this leads the police officers
to believe that they're transporting
alcohol the boys then somehow manag to
appease the offic officers with some
bribe money allowing them to proceed
after this they reach the delivery point
and successfully complete the trade
later the two best friends celebrate
their success at a bar dancing and
drinking Upon returning to crowny
magazine late that night they are
confronted by Sunny's grandfather who
has discovered their illicit activities
he is so disappointed in them that he
throws them off his premises